so we started doing some free-throw
percentage problems in the last video so
let's continue so in the first time I
said well F have an 80% free-throw
percentage what are my chances of
getting three free throws in a row and I
said well it's 51.2% chance let's let's
do another scenario with and let's just
assume that my free-throw percentage
stays at 80% and let's say that I don't
know let's say there are there are two
then let's say my team is two points
behind I'm making this up on the fly so
we're two points behind two points let's
say we're one point behind one point
behind we're one point behind and I'm up
at the free-throw line and I want to say
what what is the chance and let's say I
have three free-throws as you know
someone followed me when I was shooting
a three-pointer so we're one point
behind there's one second left one
second left and right when I was going
to take the winning free-throw or not
the winning free-throw though the
winning 3-point shot someone follows me
so I get three free throws so I get
three free throws and once again I have
an 80% free-throw percentage my actual
percentage is probably something more
like twenty percent but anyway I have
three free throws so my question is what
are our chances of winning what is the
probability of my team winning winning
not tying winning so in order to win
well actually let's let's do the the
tying first so what's the probability of
tying tying or time how do you spell tie
tying okay
what's the probability of a tie what's
the probability of tie well the
probability of a tie is going to be
equal to the probability of me getting
at least one at least at least
one free-throw right you say oh well not
to say okay that's the probability of
getting exactly 1 times the probability
of getting 2 out of 3 times plus the
probability of getting 3 out of 3 but
like we saw and I think it was either
the last video or the video before that
is identically equal to the probability
or let's say 1 minus the probability of
not getting any free-throws not getting
any free throws right but if you know
it's the probability of getting at least
one is essentially the probability of me
not missing all 3 right hopefully that
makes some sense so let me erase all
this stuff that I did up on top and we
can figure out the answer to this
problem let me erase all of this erase
all of that erase that let me erase this
we know I have an 80% probability of
making any one shot so if we go back to
the problem what is so this is my
free-throw percentage free-throw
percentage so what is the probability of
me not making any shots not making any
of my free-throws
well my probability of not making one
free-throw is 20% right 20% chance not
making any free throws or not making any
you know it would say I take a shot I
have a 20% of not not no basket we're
not making the free-throw so if I'm
taking 3 shots the check shot of I miss
all three is going to be equal to 20%
times 20% times 20% right and that
equals what this 0.2 times 0.2 is 0.04
times 0.2 right and then let's see
what's point oh four times point two oh
two let's see that'll be a
eight and I have one two three numbers
by the digits places one two three
so 0.008 so I have a point zero eight
chance of missing all of the free-throws
right or another way you could view this
is this is equal to write a percentage
is just this times owner so there's 0.8
percent chance of missing all of the
free-throws or another way of viewing
this is I have so what's my chance is
making at least one well it's going to
be one minus this so what's one minus
point this is a 0.008 well it's ninety
nine point two percent all right yeah
that's ninety nine point two percent
right ninety nine point two percent
chance or you could also do is 0.99 -
all right you take one minus this you
get point nine nine two which the same
thing as ninety nine point two percent
chance so I have a ninety nine point two
percent chance of at least tying the
game so it's pretty high if you have
someone at the free-throw line with a
with the 80% free-throw percentage and
they have three shots now what if I only
had two shots let's say I got fouled
when I was taking a two pointer and I
only have two shots well in that case in
order to tie the game have to get at
least one but I only have two shots so
it would be 1 minus the chances of me
missing both shots and what's the
chances of missing two shots well the
chance of missing two shots in a row I
have a four per is four percent right
twenty percent times twenty percent so
four percent chance of missing two shots
two in a row so my probability of
getting at least one assuming that I am
taking two shots is going to be one
minus this I have a 96% probability of
at least one shot if I take two so
that's also pretty high and of course
what's why probability if I only have
one shot
well it's eighty percent so so hopefully
that gives you a little bit of framework
next time you watch a basketball game
and you can pause your TiVo and figure
out the probability and you know when
when the person is making that last
clutch shot and it could be an
interesting experiment for you
anyway so let's and actually actually I
was thinking an interesting scientific
experiment or maybe you know a
high-school science project you know
people have a free-throw percentage and
that kind of implies that every time
someone takes a free-throw that those
are mutually exclusive events that they
are independent of the previous time
like we said with coins but an
interesting idea you know in basketball
people always say you know he's hot now
or he has a streak and so there is this
notion and I know I felt it that there
are times that your probability
increases or decreases and it tends to
be may be dependent on whether you made
or missed your previous shot so one
thing you might want to this is I think
a legitimate science project is to
either get the data from real NBA
players and see if if they really are
mutually exclusive events if if the
probability of making up the next shot
or the next free-throw really is
independent of whether they made or miss
the the previous one or whether it
actually is dependent or if you don't
have all the data from you know the NBA
or whatever although I suspect you could
find it you could try it with yourself
and your friends or you know maybe since
you want to be unbiased you'll do with
your friend you'll see is if the
probability of them making the next
free-throw really is independent of
whether they made the last one anyway
that actually I think that could be
quite quite good and you can get quite
involved in any analysis so let's let me
finish this up with another scenario we
talked about free throws we've talked
about quote flipping a coin and now I'll
talk about dice because that is really
another area where well it's one
interesting and you'll probably see some
problems on probability so in general
when you're playing games of with
involving dice it's always interesting
to say you know what's the probability
if I have two six-sided dice what's my
probability of getting I don't know a
particular number let's say what's the
probability of getting a 7 so to think
about that you have to say well what has
to happen to for the dice for me to get
a seven and I think here it might be
interesting to draw a bit of a grid so
let's say that's my grid let me split it
up into six so let's see it's splitting
it up and do one
- - each of these may be split up into
three so it'll be like that will be
perfect but close like that like that
and like that and let me split it so
you'll see what I'm doing in a second -
actually I didn't want to do that well
it's good enough this this I'm trying to
make it a 6x6
okay and the reason why I'm doing this
is because let's let's make this top
this top axis this horizontal each of
the situations I can get on the first
dice right although I'm going to roll
them simultaneously although it doesn't
matter if I roam simultaneous or one
after the other I roll one dice one
after the other
so this first dice I could get 1 a 2 a 3
a 4 a 5 or 6 so this is dice 1 D 1 and
on the second dice I can get a 1 a 2 a 3
a 4 a 5 or 6 and this is stage 2 and I'm
running out of time so I will see you in
the next video